the Sky Tree Soares above the Tokyo
Skyline it's one of the world's tallest
Towers in what is the planet's most
seismically active country people in
Japan are said to feel some 2,000
Tremors each year since 1if of the
world's earthquakes of magnitude six or
higher occur here earthquake awareness
begins at an early age regular concise
drills were also credited for saving the
lives of people who lived in these homes
affected by the Noto Peninsula Quake on
New Year's
Day we train people about where to
gather and what kind of disaster relief
system to implement so when residents
here felt a little Tremor they
immediately left their houses and
evacuated 100 years since the Great kto
Earthquake killed more than 140,000
people much has changed in the way Japan
prepares for earthquakes Japan's strict
building codes enforced in 1981 require
Engineers to fulfill two levels of
earthquake proofing firstly to guarantee
enough resilience to withstand smaller
Quakes with minimal damage and secondly
to make sure that for Tremors on a
seismic scale of 6 to 7 the building
does not collapse modern highrises are
designed to swing with the quake's
energy given their flexible construction
pendulums and dampers cut the intensity
of That Swing but Japan's gold standard
is not applied to older homes on Noto
peninsula where the elderly population
is twice the national average many
wooden properties were decimated their
owners less inclined nor able to afford
retrofitting This Disaster prevention
expert notes Tokyo is not immune to
similar Devastation as the Metropolis
prepares for its next big
one the probability of a magnitude 7
earthquake hitting the capital within 30
years is about 70% some areas especially
in eastern Tokyo have a concentration of
buildings with low Quake resistance
calls for more inclusive planning as an
increasingly unpredictable Mother Nature
is requiring communities to work
together as they have never before Unis
Kim aljazera
Tokyo that's it for make sure to
subscribe to our channel to get the
latest news from Al
jazer